los ovarios son las glándulas
reproductivas femeninas
se componen de tres tipos de células
epitelial
germinal
y esto mal
cuando las células en los ovarios crecen
de forma anormal se convierten en
tumores que pueden ser benignos o
cancerosos
si los tumores cancerosos no se detectan
a tiempo las células cancerosas pueden
propagarse desde los ovarios a través de
la región pélvica y continuar
propagándose hacia la zona abdominal y
otros órganos la determinación de la
etapa del cáncer de ovario es muy
importante en el desarrollo de un plan
de tratamiento
en la etapa 1 el cáncer se limita a uno
o ambos ovarios
en la etapa 2 el cáncer de ovario se
extiende hacia la zona de la pelvis
en la etapa 3 el cáncer de ovario se ha
propagado hacia la región abdominal
en la etapa 4 el cáncer de ovarios se
extiende hacia el hígado o ubicaciones
fuera del área abdominal
generalmente el tratamiento del cáncer
de ovario incluye cirugía
quimioterapia
terapia de radiación
o una combinación de terapias